ROMAIN MARDOT: Hello everyone.
So I'm not that great at
public speaking as Sarah.
I'm working as a
partner development
manager for the partners that
are based in central Europe
and Russia.
I'm managing Playix,
Outfit7 Seven, NordCurrent,
and many other guys.
You know, every time I have
to do such a presentation,
I'm like OK.
I hope that the
next round at least
is not coming any time soon.
And I'm not talking
only about Playtime.
But then when I'm offered
with the possibility
I accept the change.
One of the reasons
because I actually
like competing with myself.
And we all know that
actually inside someone
by creating challenge
to him, he's
more likely to participate.
This is why actually
the presentation
is called there is a
competitor in every person,
in every player.
And we know that we
are managing players
When you actually
think about it,
you know that the humanity and
people were always competitive,
right?
We always take part in different
contests, tournaments, wars.
actually.
Even the video games,
by their nature,
they are a pretty
competitive product.
There is a challenge
in every game.
They're just all different.
So today, I will
talk about what do we
mean by competitive gaming,
which is a bit more than just
finishing a different level.
Then we'll see how you can make
your game more competitive.
We'll go through three cases--
is there something
wrong with the text or?
No.
We'll go through three
keys or features,
let's say modes, that were
added to games by our partners,
many of them are in the room.
Thank you very much for sharing
the case with us every time.
It's really helpful.
Then we'll check three
games that are very
competitive by their nature.
Here, we have actually some
nice stats on guns and shooting.
That should beat on
eSports, because this
is in everyone's mind,
wrap up the presentation,
and leave you the time to
ask questions if you have.
So competitive gaming,
as I just mentioned,
how is it different
in our mind than just
finishing a different level?
So for us, it's
something that is
more involved form of gaming.
That is part of your
game that includes
the success, the
progress measurement,
and the recognition
from your game design,
and in many cases, prizes.
We know that the competitive
gaming is actually
coming on mobile from PC.
PC is still a good example
for many of our titles.
It's still the most
lasting platform
in time with the most
spread games genres, still
the one that brings
the most revenue.
It still has freemium and
premium distribution model.
We have a lot of
hardcore titles that
are just being sold without
having any subscription
or [INAUDIBLE] plans.
We know that the popularity
of competitive games
is still growing, on whether
they're just hardcore titles
or whether they are part
of the eSports like "League
of Legends" and other titles.
And we know that thanks to the
strong word of mouth factor,
those games are very popular.
So this is what helping.
Now if we compare it on
mobile, what we have?
We know that this
trend is growing,
but this trend is
having some changes.
They are all listed here.
First of all,
because the biggest
majority of competitive gamers
are free to play on mobile.
It's pretty hard to balance
your customers spent
and the feeling that you
are doing something right.
The equal chances to win.
The form factor.
Touch controls, pretty
hard to make them
really handy and competitive.
Network issues, not always the
best connection to make you
feel very immersed in your game.
The game genres, not
always available.
Not all types of
games are currently
available on mobile games.
And every session lengths.
Depending on the game
generally, it's pretty short.
So it's pretty hard to stick
someone to your product.
We've been talking about
retention, all these changes
that you guys have in general.
However, when we talked
about competitive gaming,
we all know that
the level of mastery
is something that counts a lot.
The more the player feels that
he's managing the processes--
the game-- the
more he's engaged.
In fact, for us and in this
case, this is a synonym.
So when brainstorming about
the competitive gaming,
we were actually
asking ourselves
what additional
features or game modes
you can add to your game to
make them more competitive,
considering the fact
that they are already
a competitive product.
Making something competitive
more competitive, nice.
OK then the captain
obvious jumps into the room
and says that's, OK the
more hardcore is your title,
the more competitive It is.
So one of the solutions that you
have is just simply designing--
if you don't have
a project yet--
a product that is more hardcore.
The more hardcore it is,
the more competitive it is.
Thanks, Mr. Captain.
But then if you
already have a product
on whether it's casual or ready
mid-core or hardcore game,
you can actually
improve it and make
it more competitive for the
players by adding features.
Here it's just a
simple slide that
goes from the more
soft core features
that you can add to your
product to the most hardcore.
We all know that league,
ladders, achievements,
single PvE missions
are really good.
They usually actually
help your players
discovering the content.
You remember they
are not developers,
they just play your game.
Contests and co-op PvE can
be online for the contests,
offline as well.
co-op PvE there is
more engagement.
This helps players
to socialize, to have
common goals to achieve.
Then single player
and team player PvP
is one of the best
things that you
can do to engage your
players even more,
to make them compete even more.
And then when it's a single
player or team player
direct PvP because
we know that there
are a lot of games currently
running a sync PvP modes.
This is in more hardcore.
eSports, I'm just putting
it here for the moment,
because obviously, then people
are asking, why you are not
talking about eSports.
I will touch a bit on that
later in my presentation.
So those are the modes, the
features that you can introduce
if you are lacking of ideas.
So now I will go through
three cases of features
that were added to casual
mid-core games by our partners
and see what results
it has produced--
like kind of case studies.
So here again,
thank you very much,
guys for sharing the
information with us.
We have three titles.
One is "Cooking
Fever" by Nordcurrent,
"Talking" Tom Gold
Run by Outfit7,
and "Nonstop Knight"
by Flaregames.
I decided to put the three
products side by side,
because I'm focusing on features
rather than on game design.
We believe that
some ideas can be
easily interchangeable
between the products
if you want to make
them competitive.
So what happened is
that in "Cooking Fever"
the partner has
other tournaments.
Tournaments is a
feature where people
have to complete biggest
number of levels.
And then the results
are being compared
between different players.
In "Talking Tom Gold Run",
they introduced a PvE racing
contest.
This game is a runner.
And in this case, instead of
running against just the timer,
you're running
against the machine.
And then again, your
results are being compared.
And what happened in
the "Nonstop Knight"
is that developer introduced
a massive boss fight
event, where people
have to come in groups
to fight different bosses.
So they have to
plan accordingly.
This feature is a
bit more hardcore.
So what happened in the
end is that actually
all of these changes
had a great impact
on players' engagement
and the increase
of the daily active
users and people
who take part in the tournament
and the monetization metrics.
We can see, for example,
that almost 300,000 people
took place in the mode
introduced to "Cooking Fever".
And actually 50% of
people get back to it.
We can actually see that the
impact it had on the revenue
was of the same importance of
some level-ups and sales that
were conducted in
the game before.
And actually, the developer
has reported that this event
can be recreated.
And with time, producing
the same effect.
In "Talking Tom Gold Run" here,
again, very successful case
where the users started
playing the game more,
actually increasing the average
time spent by one minute.
It's a lot.
And they find a way on how
to oblige users to spend
more of their in-game currency.
I know that
sometimes some of you
are having trouble actually
with how to wash out
this extra currency that
players managed to accumulate
and, therefore, are not
spending real money anymore.
In the "Nonstop Knight",
the results actually
were pretty spectacular.
The number of daily active
users has increased a lot.
And the daily customer
spent has followed as well.
So now if you are a
casual game developer,
and we take the pros
and cons and the data
that we have seen before, we
know that going casual gaming
is good.
Because the games
have simple mechanics,
because they have mass appeal,
low barrier of entry-- people
understand them easily and
they have good replay value.
It's a lot of content that
people can play again.
But in the same
time, you're probably
facing challenges like
the fact that they
are pretty easy to copy--
I'm not pretending that any
game can be copied but still--
that you are fighting with
other companies that probably
fight for the same customer as
you, and low conversion rate.
So overall, if you
help people and players
with bringing them more common
challenges, socializing better,
and track all the
progress, it should
help you increasing your
engagement and metrics overall.
Well, this is at least what
our partners have tried.
This is in what we believe.
And this is what we
decided to share with you.
OK so this is for
the casual segment.
Next part is about
mid-core, hardcore gaming.
And as I mentioned, those three
titles I'll be talking about
are really about competition.
The game design is
competitive by nature.
So first product is
the one that people--
a lot of people are
currently staring at,
because it's actually
pop up from nowhere.
It is showing
incredible performance.
And it's actually a very,
very cool game beyond all.
So called "Last Game on Earth",
zombie PvP slash survivor,
slash RPG crafting.
Actually, this game
has everything in it.
And when it was released and
started performing incredibly,
it was actually and is still
in the beta stage, kind of.
Beta, beta is, you
know, a very handy term.
So actually beta
is important here
because when the game was
released four months ago,
it had only like 20% of features
that the partner managed
to implement, because
they were actually
a bit surprised by success
but at the same time, having
great plans.
And just with this
20% of features
but with a good overview of
what is coming next in the game,
they were able to obtain
incredible results.
So those are like the first
metrics and actually thank you,
the partner never
minded actually sharing
the full information with us.
You will see actually the next
slides are pretty incredible.
So currently, the
developer is working
on the introduction
of these modes that
are still not in the game.
And they will be
actually focusing
a lot on the competition
and more players.
And you can see that we have
a good range of different PvP
scenarios, co-op scenarios,
and direct PvP confrontation.
So remember that I
just said that only 20%
of what was planned was
introduced to the game.
And this is actually how
the daily active users
curve is behaving right now.
So this is the real data
provided by the developer
since the game launch.
So as you can see, the
number of daily active users
is pretty impressive.
But what is actually
more impressive--
this is like the cherry
on the top of the cake--
is that revenue that this
currently generated by Android.
And here again, this is
actually their achieved results.
There is one key
takeaway actually would
like to take from this case.
This is actually, as
I just mentioned it,
what you actually show and
what you allow players to plan
can actually help you a lot
in terms of your further game
development choices.
Even though if you
don't have the time
to implement everything
that you have planned,
try to work with the
community to show them
that this is coming by
any means that you have,
because this is important.
Because if players they know
that this kind of content
is coming, they will gather
resources, invest their time,
and plan accordingly.
And this helps you actually
engaging them on a longer term.
Two next cases.
So during many
years, no one dared
to make a true first
person shooter mobile.
But then we actually had
an industry veteran--
which is not presented
on this slide--
but somehow came up
with a crazy idea.
I'm naming Mud Fingers and
their game called "The Trigger".
They decided to put out a
shooting in the first person
shooters so that we
don't have to fight
against your mobile phone.
Every time you have an
enemy in your scope,
it shoots automatically.
And actually, based on that, we
have two incredible developers
that made two really cool
first person shooters
and released them on Android.
On the left, we
have "Monostrike"
with actually a
pretty big number
of installs and "Guns Of Boom".
Both games feels differently,
but they feel very immersive.
And they have
different settings.
The left arm feels more
like "Counter-strike"
The right one feels to me
more like "Team Fortress."
Then it depends on what
kind gamer you are.
Obviously, those
games, as I mentioned,
they're competitive by nature.
So they're already
inciting players
who love first person
shooters coming
to mobile to try them out.
But in their current
development stage,
both partners have chosen a
slightly different strategies
to people working
with their community.
On one side-- actually, sorry.
There is one slide missing.
On one side,
"Monostrike" is keeping
on increasing the deepness
of the mastery of the weapons
and the feedback the players
get from the progress they
have in the game.
Whereas, on the other
side, gaming side
are focusing a lot on
the work and the feedback
they get from the community.
They put a big stress
on the tournaments
and the interactions the
players might have together--
how they compete
against each other.
Besides, that,
actually, I would like
to put a special stress
on the whole work that is
being done with the community.
Actually, you have
all the channels
that allow you to
broadcast your content
and share it with the players
that the partner is currently
using.
The Video Hub section
is, for instance,
introduced in the game.
There is a lot of content
that is being created
on a daily basis by the
players using YouTube Gaming,
YouTube overall, and
popular YouTube vloggers.
Here again, different focus
but good results for both.
While Azure Games
are focusing, as I
said, on the feedback
the players got
and the deepness
of their weapons,
they have pretty decent results.
Every time they introduce
those features to the game,
they can be seen the left.
While working hard
with the community,
Game Inside have something--
that in my opinion-- is
very precious nowadays.
We all know that the competition
is actually really strong
and the user
acquisition are growing.
But designing a game that
can be promoted through other
means than just standard
user acquisition channels,
and in this case, a
strong word of mouth.
And this we mentioned
in our session
before, YouTube videos, that
can sometimes actually promote
your product much
better than any campaign
that you can design is
actually driving a lot of users
to this product, making it
overall very successful,
creating stable users'
behavior, good retention,
and overall, good revenue.
So here again, if
we do the same size
as we did for the
casual games, we
know that if you haven't
decided that you decided
to go hardcore,
you should go there
because those kind
of games allow
you to attract different users.
Because they are
more impressive,
they have more complex
control schemes,
they allow you to
add more deepness.
In the same time,
don't forget that you
will be always actually
competing with other platforms.
As I mentioned at the
beginning of my presentation,
PC is still the one that is
the most hardcore and that
attracts the attention
from a lot of players.
And then using the examples
that they have just given,
you can use those tips to work
better with your community.
The most important key
takeaway is the way
you work with the community.
I know that on mobile,
it's pretty hard
to move your player from the
gaming process to a forum page
or to wherever else where you
have a message tailored to him.
However, if the players know
that you care about them
and you tailor those messages
and constantly working on it,
they come.
They listen to your feedback.
And they work with you,
which allows you much better
interactions.
So never give up and
listen to you community,
and share your information
about your plans.
So we were talking about
competitive gaming.
And actually, there is
the E-sports subject.
You know, the eSports
on mobile reminds me
about like flying saucers.
Everyone is talking
about, them but no one
has ever seen it, kind of.
So what's the challenge
for eSports on mobile?
First, it's a good opportunity.
We know according to
the super data stats--
and we actually don't even
need to get the statistic--
that this subject has an
enormous outreach potential.
There are a lot of people
who watch tournaments.
They take part in them,
they watch and play.
They are like separate
and different groups.
But on mobile, it's not
truly effective yet.
Actually, I haven't heard anyone
like giving a proper definition
on what is eSport
on mobile so far.
Probably because eSports on
mobile have these challenges.
And they need to comply
with these things.
So the game needs
to be free to win.
Right?
If you want to have
a truly eSport title,
it has to be free to win.
Synchronous battles, I
think it's an obvious point.
Actually, if you can make a
game that is playable in team,
it will be a big plus.
Show a certain level of mastery.
Well, I guess we're
talking about eSports.
So if it's just a
casual title, you
can't make it really
an eSport title.
Last in time, we know that
once you create a community,
you have to always
feed with new content,
new plans for tournaments,
new prizes, and so on.
So if your product is not
respecting this point,
you cannot call it
an eSport title.
And one of the most
important things
is to get spectators'
attention, because if I offer
you like football tickets
to to a match of two teams
that you have never heard
about, you will probably
never go to see the game.
But if it's Brazil
playing against France
and if you're not
even a football fan,
you will probably go and see it
just for the check-box point.
So here is the
challenge with which
the mobile game, in my
opinion, is fighting against.
It's making sure that
the product that you're
designing for
being an eSport one
is interesting to
watch while being
played from a mobile device.
If I would stop here, I think
I would leave an empty spot.
But again, in my opinion, the
right games that are already
kind of switchable and
respect those rules,
I came up here with
three examples.
But actually, if we looked
for them, we can find more.
So those three titles
respect all the rules
and can potentially
become true eSport titles.
What is also
interesting to know is
that we have a
couple of developers
that are working
on titles that will
be really interesting,
at least in terms
of the competitive gaming.
I'm not sure on
whether they will
be able to put them
to eSport level.
But I just wanted to share
with you on what is coming.
I actually am gamer myself
and watching into this subject
very much.
So we have at least
two cool titles
coming from War Gaming, which
one is "World of Tanks",
a World of Warships blitz.
It's a big franchise coming.
We have Wargaming in the room.
Having actually seven versus
seven team battles, which
is pretty exceptional
immobile and this title
will be very
competitive by the way.
And "Warfre" this
game is actually
coming in "StarCraft"
like ish setting,
having direct PvP battles,
which is also kind of cool.
And then we actually have two
really exceptional titles,
one by the veteran
that I mentioned
at the very beginning.
Those guys actually
doing an amazing job
in terms of bringing
triple A class
title on mobile,
where people will
be fighting in big MMO world.
And actually, even the
most successful PvP players
will get statutes inside
the capital cities
as one of the factors
to motivate them.
And then we have a very cool
"Second World War" title.
So what can I tell more?
Actually, you know, we've
talked about competition.
We talked about eSports.
And we actually all know
that the augmented reality
is really trendy.
And here again, we have partners
that are doing exceptional work
in this turn.
And actually, I want
to share with you
a video that showcases
an ER mode that allows
you to spectate game matches.
So if we can run
the video, please.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Was supposed to be removed, OK.
Well.
So yeah.
I hope that you were
inspired by this presentation
because I believe that
working a lot of with figures
and conversions, life is
a matter of conversion.
So if by my speech I
converted to you today
to start to work on a
more competitive feature
in your game, we'll
get results soon.
And the hardest part
is to go to start.
Just to wrap up
the session, those
are, in my opinion, the
five most important points
that you should take away.
Is that it's important to build
competitive modes in your game,
but you have to choose the
level of competition that
depends on the player.
Allowing-- and as I
mentioned-- the progress
showing the progress to
players is very important.
Players, even on mobile, like
direct PvP if PS is trendy--
first person shooters--
there is still
some Room because there
is less competition.
But a big pool of
partners are coming.
When designing competition
features, still bear in mind
the montenization.
Because if you
increase engagement
but it doesn't have
an impact on the way
you monetize your
players, you will still
have some homework to do.
And the cool game design
and cool game features
nowadays will allow
you to promote
your game through other
channels than just
paid user acquisition.
So I hope that this
was interesting.
And now I am ready to answer
your questions if you have
any.